well there was no shortage of liberal
media misfires this year so we thought
we'd break down some of the media's
biggest missteps of 2021 and there were
a lot here to help us is fox news
contributor joe concha who better to
walk us through some of these uh joe
welcome
you again i just saw you yesterday on
the five i can't get rid of hoya saxa
ahoya saxa that's right we georgetown it
for the viewers who don't know that but
anyway joe so let's get to this first
one uh perhaps the biggest media misstep
of 2021 was the framing of kyle
rittenhouse let's take a listen
okay johnson you have written house a
white teenager who crossed state lines
with an ar-15 style rifle who came
across state lines with a firearm that
he purchased illegally driven by his
mother the right celebrates the written
house acquittal while the growing
obsession with the vigilante justice is
an active threat to american society
wow guys all of them
joe we need some accountability here
absolutely look the written house trial
encapsulated media malfeasance to the
point an entire college course could be
taught about it basic rules broken here
kelly right the defendant guilty until
proven innocent i'm pretty sure you went
to law school as you know that's not how
the system works uh race was a central
theme as well despite the trial
involving what three white guys shooting
three other white guys in self-defense
and then you had a network the one you
just played msnbc they were tossed from
covering the trial after they chased the
jury van back to its hotel witness
intimidation even running a red light in
the process to do so a hot mess and a
dumpster fire fortunately the justice
system got it right kyle rittenhouse
obviously exonerated and maybe
celebrated a little bit too much at this
point for my taste but regardless at
least the justice system ignored the
media coverage here kaley
yeah and then there was this one
remember all those voters who showed up
in virginia and voted based on education
and critical race theory and they
elected a republican governor well
apparently it was all figment of their
imagination roll the tape
critical race theory
which isn't real
you oppose critical race theory being
taught in schools which i should say is
not part of virginia's curriculum he has
specifically targeted the issue of
education
and and what he calls critical race
theory even though it's not taught in
virginia schools
what can i say kelly uh media elites
like you played there in new york and
washington they can claim all they like
that crt isn't being taught in virginia
schools or elsewhere parents in the
commonwealth parents across this country
they knew better when watching that
coverage they saw the curriculums they
spoke to their children the teachers
that were brave enough to defy their
union bosses also spoke out critical
race theory being shoved down students
throats it completely flies in the face
of the mantra of dr martin luther king i
much rather my kids learn more about him
because he preached to judge others not
by the color of their skin but by the
content of their character crt does the
exact opposite of that meanwhile we're
25th in the world in writing math and
science maybe we get back to that
blocking and tackling instead of
concentrating on race all the time
fortunately the virginia governor's race
showed that parents have had enough
kayley
oh they've had enough and the november
22 midterms will show the same uh and
then there's this one as well joe so
that pricey receipt you have at the
grocery store that check that just shows
how expensive your meal is at a
restaurant the gas prices here's what
the media has to say about all that
all right so the economy isn't
bad it's just that people are mad
because everything is late and things
cost a little bit more one of the
reasons prices are up is because people
can afford to pay those prices
fascinating uh what can you say kelly
it's fun when the richest one percent
are telling you that things aren't that
bad meanwhile you read poll after poll
ninety percent of the country says
inflation is something they're deeply
concerned with that's 170 million people
saying boy this is having a big impact
not 170 million i'm doing my math wrong
320 million right uh half say that
inflation is directly causing hardship
on its household particularly in the low
and middle class right because they
can't absorb all these price increases
when it comes to food and gas and
heating their homes and it's the usual
disconnect between elites in newsrooms
and what people are feeling on the
ground bottom line is abc news poll just
out seven in 10 americans disapprove of
president biden's handling of inflation
when you want to spend trillions and uh
you've already spent trillions this year
already uh that that can do that and
look you could self-peddle this all you
like but americans simply are not buying
it kelly
oh but joe biden and ron claim tell us
it's transitory so don't worry about
that joe koncha
and you remember those border agents who
were apparently whipping migrants that
just totally egregious live from the
media let's flash back to that
all right we saw that image of at least
one border patrol agent using a whip and
was effectively trying to lasso some of
the migrants you see that picture there
as an image
to me it does smack of a bygone era
of slavery
chris cuomo
wow that feels like 80 years ago seeing
chris cuomo uh patronizing people on
television yeah look uh it was a rush to
judgment led by the president of the
united states and those in his
administration mr biden owes those
agents a public apology i never really
heard much about that investigation by
the way while those agents were
suspended the media members that pushed
this bs they knew better yet they went
ahead and with that narrative anyway now
they have egg on their faces of course
but apologies as you know it's just not
in the dna of many people in this
business unfortunately kelly i gotta
know before we go it's gonna be 2022
soon what is your resolution mine is to
lose weight the wife just said i look
like him in my second trimester not good
want to hear yours since weight
obviously clearly is not an issue
not true well mine is to be present and
when i have those rare moments off of
work to be present with my daughter and
my husband not on my phone put the
device aside so bring down the screen
time joe i want to make this final point
have you noticed a trend and everything
we're walking through uh that the
ivermectin story that was such a lie
that oklahomans were overdosing on
ivermectin and pushing gunshot wound
victims out of hospital what was
oklahoma well a republican state
the 60 minutes lie about governor
desantis well what's governor desantis a
republican of a successful state the
state of florida all the lies tend to go
in one direction and that's against the
right and against republicans so anyway
joe thanks so much for being here had to
make that point pretty obvious to our
viewers but worth saying
journalism has become activism in many
circles unfortunately kelly i think
that's the overall theme that we're
seeing it's no longer about bias it's
trying to control a narrative and change
an outcome and that's a scary thing
kelly
yeah well thank you for being here happy
new year and you don't need to lose
weight
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now